bella tutti ragazzi e per me perché sono
video sono fa vj e non ci siamo tornati
subito gol simulator stavo dicendo sul
saggio un simulatore the lady il camice
ogni volta che faccio sti episodi è un
tipo muoio di caldo però non importa non
si è mai visto credo un dottore con la
collana dei doni della morte
siccome di altri ragazzi abbiamo fatto
abbiamo fatto il trapianto gli utenti a
quello di ho chiesto di fantastici cioè
si può fare saggia un simulator in
corsia come cazzo si inizia tra l'altro
ha inizio perfetto mi ricordavo
veramente ci fosse la corsia lanciava
mente l'anno aggiunta sta cosa al sexy
sono che faceva a ok ci sono i carretti
carrelli che si muovono perfetta milioni
riusciti a fare un trapianto a chi a
pugni alzati lato alla porta siamo
partiti bene io tiro pugnale porte
giustamente fatto mi sono passati merda
mi sono incastrato la mano e mi
servirebbe un marte ci avete un martello
niente continua a sbattere sulla porta
c'è un cazzo di martello per fare
l'operazione o niente con la tazza
ragazza che è meglio forse c'è di qua
non c'è notte frega come cazzola pro
torace sto tizio è impossibile piove
come cazzo fa più avrei un ospedale va
bè ragazzi avete delle perdite su ai
costi un martello lo trova fermi servizi
no merda minchia non ce la faccio non ci
posso credere mi incazzo [ __ ] a
milioni di prendere sta cazzo 18 ecco sì
l'ho preso perchè botta di culo mezz'ora
solo per prendere sta merda
non so se è normale vabbè comunque io
vedo di spaccare tutto il pre gara da
troppo tempo che non facevo che non
giocava so già che ti piace il martello
qualcosa mi dice di no a reja lega non
mi ricordo come si fa al trapianto di
cuore abbiate pazienza se prende un
cavallo sono fuori sì sì tra ragazzi
vendo polmone su ebay non so di assi
come te e tu a questo coso meme la dc
che cosa non si capisce
c'è chi dorme con i pupazzi ragazzi di
donne con i pupazzi e se chi dorme coi
polmoni lega è una scelta di vita
insomma alcuna voglia di spiegarmi come
taglio le forbici e forbici
si no no la colla certo a regalare la
farm in attivo non solo si fa perché è
perfetto fantastico eccolo qui ragazzi
mi sta morendo
no non ho visto [ __ ] operazione
non riuscita andava tutto bene certo a
parte le porte che sbattono
riproviamo un attimo questa cosa non
l'ho capita bene poi spagna radio questa
è la posto tipo prendere o cazzo non
voleva ascoltati o della giusti tu
perché io non puoi non c'è da fare ecco
la perfetto oddio no ma no cosa faccia
il mio braccio di massa una mappa ancora
incastrarmi nei carrelli la cell accetta
è meglio di niente tagliare la
strumentale più facile regala siringa a
sync non ho niente mi sono punto fante
io sono un [ __ ] perché adesso devo
fare l'operazione in corsia da drogato
meraviglioso riccio ecco l'altra siringa
che culo perfetto ragazzi oggi del terzo
e vj insegnerà a farne opera siano essi
queste prime jerne di ospedale tra via
prima ha fatto esperienza quell'allegra
chirurga siccome aveva che si queste
prime share degli ospedali vedo aver
fatto esperienza con l'allegro chirurgo
con la lega chiaro il globe perché se
non funziona perché se noi non
imparerete me prima cosa mettiamo prime
case mettiamo bottiglietta d'acqua
dentro il nostro paziente nel caso
avesse 7 seconda cosa mettiamo nel gene
nostro paziente perché ovviamente giusto
per controllare l'ora del decesso mi sta
morendo lega come cazzo faccio anch'io
ragazzi questa questo è quella buona
perché è volato un polmone a caso ecco
cos'è questa cosa va beh io nel dubbio
butto tutto vicino al pazzo intanto li
riconosce tutto ragazze sono stavolta
non ci riescono non so perché è
impossibile si può togliere sto schifo
che mezz'ora che se grazie a dio
glielo lascio qui amico mio perché
almeno quando si sveglia lo trova
come non detto li lasciamo a ridare
quella nuova ragazzi poi posso metterlo
il problema è che non arriva però nel
dubbio prendo la colla ecco questo
questo può sostituire un cuore forse non
lo so non ne sono sicuro amico mio sì
come core e non arriva gradisce per caso
una tazza di tè ad arrivare questa merda
di cui veloce però
ma [ __ ] è va bene ma io mai sto
schifo chiave ragazzi non si può perdere
perché non arrivò al cuore non ha senso
questo mi muore non conviene tanto
condotte rabbia i doni della morte
di sicuro il quale mani basse da qualche
parte un sodo eccolo minchia [ __ ]
ragazzi ci ho messo qualcosa come mezzo
andai adesso però non ok sapere tutto a
posto sono certo che vivrà fantastiche
ragazze non so quanto terna ragazza è
stato bassa del range ho messo anni
avevo paura che non me la prendo essa la
fine non lo so perché va bene quanto ci
sono limiti cos'è questo i ragazzi mi do
sbloccare tutto ma che sono troppo
curioso funziona solo qualcosa mi dice
che non funziona primavera chiunque
programma quella quella qui è il
trapianto di reni sempre in in corsia ma
vabbè fantastica sarà corsera cacciami
belle ragazze che si sfondano le porte
stupendo con ragazzi o prima mi sono
dimenticato di fare la cosa più
importante che lo step numero uno e devo
dirvelo
la prima regola per un buon dottore è
quello di vedere se il paziente è morto
effettivamente tipo anzi lo prendete la
mascherina lo sbatta chiatte da una
parte all'altra giusto prevedere se
sbaglio potete anche a schiaffeggiarlo
volendo c'è come volete ragazzi il
secondo passo ragazzi è quello di
mandarlo a [ __ ] mentre sta dormendo
per vedere se si sveglia e si incazza
appello del signora vedi questo nel
deretano subito è una volta fatto questi
ragazzi si può procedere all'operazione
che è la cosa più importante in teoria e
come si fa se la vedo un po due ragazzi
non per delle ossa con una bottiglia di
plastica però mi servirebbe il martello
ragazzi sono passati secoli da l'ultima
volta ho fatto un trapianto di cose che
devo tra i reni perfetto che ai più che
ad ogni serve la siringa
no sì mi chiamo sorpreso ecco perché per
fermare l'emorragia ragazzi siringhe
nell'orecchio perfetto che la tiene in
tutti e un attimo giusto per grazie
molto gentile le ossa non servono a un
cazzo tutto quello che hanno spiegato è
una bugia non servono un cazzo non può
non solo le palle mi servirebbe sì che
questo prendo tutto a culo non so come
faccio
ci sono i dottori che impugnano i propri
strumenti nel mondo giusto
e poi ci sono io che lo faccio a modo
mio
niente celar ce l'ha incastrato nel
minio non è possibile che la persona va
beh c'è qualcuno mi spiega perchè cazzo
è morto non soltanto ficcato non sono
fare del bene però soltanto sembra lì la
vita
tutto quello che si fa tardi c'è il
bowling ma [ __ ] dove dove sei
incastrata adesso al posto del sangue li
metteranno un copri stomaco però io non
sento un cazzo per primo il caso ragazzi
si pittura di verde lo stomaco le
proprie pazienti in modo tale da non lo
sarebbe anche bello che lavoro brutto sì
sì no sì un cazzo mi si toglie sto
schifo
tagliamo piano piano se ho fatto che
volevo trovare nel datemi la siringa
proci che morendo mi sta morendo veloce
veloce siringhe c'è bravo
no non mi è sembrato non ci voglio
credere
come vi avevo già insegnato ragazzi si
firmano i reni dei pazienti modo tale
che sia anche se la vostra creazione
questa perfetto in teoria togliere
togliere pezzi inutili tipo tipo questo
coso che ancora non ho capito che cos'è
prova bene sì mi chiacchie botta di culo
ragazzi l'ho tolto non sia bassa sono un
genio se riuscissi tipo a prendere rene
niente non ci riesca impossibile
ricaricarmi mi danno nervoso quando non
riesco a prendere porca [ __ ] st droga
ma ho sbagliato mi remoto brutti te lo
infilerei lei mi servirebbe una sir in
qualcuna una sera si può fare ok senti
scurati l'orecchio forse qua se che ho
trovato fino ad ora vediamo se riesco a
drogarmi anche stavolta non so se riesco
perno o no eb affanculo [ __ ] a
questa tre in fila nel a caso certo
facendo ragazzi no ti regalo questa
collana bellissima che puoi portarti non
lo so in vacanza una cosa molto carina
rialzi si no te lo passo è trapassato
passami camminare tua zia che chiedere
in testa la lascio qui è come se
riuscissi a niente ovviamente mi è
rimasta una forbice dentro
prendilo quanto scommettete che non ce
la farò a prenderla fatta scommessa
propria ma avete vinto tutti dai però è
come faccio a prenderli tutti e due in
tempo non ce la farò mai
viene anche un neanche uno scommettete
161 sì dài veloce l'ho preso ho preso
preso che quello che riesco a togliere
l'altro in tempo ragazzo forse non ce la
posso fare né impossibile però c'è non
c'è non si toglie questa merda
senti si può fare con tre reni da
hackett race meglio che 2
no non morire numeri non ti prego mi
incazzo mi incazzo dai mi incazzo una
siringa una siringa una siringa questo
gioco è input sono partito sono già
drogato ma che cazzo ce la faccio
ragazzi non ce la fa mi sta dando io
lancio la tastiera tra poco e non così
come fai a incastrati su un osso di
merda l'ho rifatto da zero di nuovo per
riuscire arrivare fino a questo punto
perché non se riesco a mettermi si 11 ha
fatto quando mandò a spostare su solo
questo ragazzo ce la posso fare
[Musica]
operazione completata mi sembra tutto
posso sono certo che libera no perché lo
ammazzo subito dopo tutti ragazzi ce
l'ho fatta con troppi alti ai reni è
stato tragico praticamente carne il caso
vi serva qualche trapianto qualcosa
sapete a chi rivolgere non chiacchiere
che possono chiudere qui se mi ricordo
dove lasciato il telecomando sono chiude
con questo servizio è piaciuto ragazzi
come al solito è stato un commento mi
piace anche a pagani facebook come la tv
non trattare descrizione sono se dovessi
descrivermi ci vediamo nel prossimo
video delle ragazze